today I'm going to be speaking with
Andrew koppelman who is a law professor
at Northwestern University and also
author of the book out today Burning
Down The House how libertarian
philosophy was corrupted by delusion and
greed it's not just the delusion it's
also the greed which I think is
important really great having you on I
appreciate it it's a coalition it's a
college very happy to be here so okay I
mean I think maybe the way to start
talking about this is I is a progressive
on the left I uh air on the side of
small L libertarianism when given the
choice between
authoritarianism and libertarianism
unless there's a really good compelling
reason to get a government or some
Authority involved I say stay out of it
and of course there are so many
exceptions to this that's like my
general idea but when we talk about
libertarian philosophy in the way you
talk about in the book you're not really
talking about what I'm talking about
which is a small L libertarian leaning
is that right
that's right I I think that the Common
Ground between us is the idea that if
the point of government what we should
be aiming at in government is giving
everybody the means to decide for
themselves how they're going to live
their lives and uh now that is a very
new idea in human history uh for most of
human history the point of the state was
the greater glory of King Sargon or at
the Triumph of the two religion or the
Triumph of the master race or uh you
know something other than the
flourishing of the individual so really
the argument between I you and me and
the Libertarians is an argument about
strategy how does one go about building
a world in which people are free to live
as they like and what's distinctive
about the Libertarians is a very strong
view that the way to assure that is to
[ __ ] the state to limit the power of
the state if only the state were
radically limited only protected our
persons and property and did nothing
else we would be Freer when you talk
about the delusion part it would be
great to hear a little bit about what
you mean you know I've experienced
conversations with Libertarians that
devolve into you know strange
conversations about everybody makes
their own Road and puts tolls on it or
you I'm sure you've heard in popular
media the way that these conversations
often go what is the delusion part that
you you're talking about well the
delusion is the idea that in order to
live the lives that we want that we can
do without uh the kind of big powerful
state that we have had uh certainly in
the United States in the last uh 100
years uh because there are quite a lot
of things that uh keep us from living
Our Lives the way that we want which do
not consist of either the government or
other people encroaching on our property
uh I mean one good example is covid uh
didn't violate anybody's rights but the
reason why we were able to beat it back
is because government raised an awful
lot of money with taxation Libertarians
hate taxation big government gave a lot
of money to private investors who would
not have invested the money themselves
in developing a vaccine and it was a
partnership between government and the
private sector that made it possible for
us to go back to something approaching
normal life without that I think that we
would still be hunkered down in our
houses fearful of death every time we're
in a room with a group of strangers yeah
that that's really interesting you know
oftentimes the word coercive comes up in
conversations with with Libertarians and
you know whether it's applied to taxes
or business regulations or the IRS at
the end of the day if you just refuse to
pay your taxes eventually someone
arrests you and you could potentially
you know the this concept of coercion it
seems to me that that if you step back a
little bit from politics and just think
about anthropology and uh so many other
fields of study there's this idea that
once you get to a group larger than 150
often is the number that's mentioned 150
humans you sort of need to have some
decisions made from the top in order to
be able to grow as a society beyond that
and and so even if there is a little bit
of coercion don't we need a little
coercion in order to be able to to live
as a modern society
well I think that it's a mistake to
think of it in terms of size the
question is not a little coercion or a
lot of coercion but the right amount of
coercion so one example that I think
that libertarian uh you know libertarian
philosophers who are who I engage with
primarily in the book because
libertarianism is political philosophy I
think well if there's a minimal thing
for the state to do it's to keep people
from harming other people well one way
in which I we can harm other people is
by pollution uh you and I can agree to
have me make a product that you buy and
it makes me better off and he makes you
better off and that's the great thing
about markets but in the if in the
course of manufacturing the thing that
you want to buy I poison all the
children in a three-mile radius of my
factory then now I'm not adding value to
the world now you and I are conspiring
to hurt a bunch of innocent people well
so how do you fix that you're not going
to fix it with private lawsuits because
it's hard for each of the victims to
prove that they've been harmed the only
way to do it is with regulation that
limits what you can put in the air and
if you want to have that kind of
Regulation you need a government with a
huge staff of scientists to try to
figure out which chemicals are harmful
and which aren't you cannot fix this
problem without big government you talk
in the book as you mentioned about
figures like Robert nozick you talk
about Hayek we hear a lot about iron
Rand and the Koch brothers and all of
these different players that are often
Loosely described as as Libertarians of
some sort of flavor
modern libertarianism has been
influenced the most by who of these
characters or others that you engage
with in the book
well the common sense libertarianism
that an awful lot of people uh hold the
sort of you know Common Sense minimal
State idea really owes the most to a
Murray rothbard who is the most
important political philosopher you
never heard of he's the one who uh
shaped the early libertarian party he's
the one who persuaded Charles Koch to
start funding libertarian causes he's
the one who met young Robert nozick when
he was a graduate student and got him
interested in this stuff he also
mentored Randy Barnett who was The
Mastermind of the legal challenge to
Obamacare
um and uh so I think he's the most
important of the lot and I talk about
all of these people in the book uh which
is basically describes the way in which
libertarian thought has evolved over
time and he was fundamentally an
anarchist but uh you know one way of uh
taking his line of thought is to which I
guess people who are not willing to go
all the way to anarchism have gone is to
say well whatever else we do let's
minimize the power of the state and the
authority of the state and while that's
still not uh the official line of the
Republican party it has enormous
influence there Trump didn't talk in
broadly libertarian terms but you look
at what actually got passed when the
Republicans had both houses and the
presidency they did a big tax cut for
the rich they nearly took Health Care
away from 20 million people and they got
it administrative agencies like the EPA
which I just goes to the thing I said at
the beginning about a coalition
libertarianism draws two different kinds
of people one is philosophers like
nozick who have a story to tell about
what a just state is and the other part
of the coalition question is business
people who'd like to be able to hurt
people without being bothered by the
police
yeah I mean but I'm curious in terms of
the modern Republican party because
you're sort of mentioning a little bit
about the the rhetoric versus the things
that were passed under Trump in those
those couple years
in the modern Republican party kind of
in the Maga direction that that it has
gone it seems nationalism is a big thing
it seems as though
authoritarianism when it is convenient
to you it has become an increasingly big
feature is there any real traditional
libertarianism that is still kind of
left or prominent in the modern
Republican Party
well the libertarianism that remains
prominent is a desire to constrain the
state the formula of the Republican
party for a long time has been to talk
populist while doing big favors for Rich
supporters and so you see that in uh
what continues to be the target of uh
the Republicans the modern
administrative State uh
the administrative state is really
inconvenient for business so you tell
people you tell ordinary working people
that you know I'm going to protect you
from these arrogant government
bureaucrats who don't respect you
and then you limit the capacity of the
bureaucrats to deliver clean water and
safe workplaces and clean air and so the
consequence is that then you tell uh
your ordinary working person look I
saved you from the bureaucrats and as a
consequence that ordinary working person
does not live long enough to meet his
grandchildren yeah I mean I guess the
the desire to limit the power of the
state is seems to be only in ways that
those on what's perceived to be the left
want to have the state involved right
because in many other ways in terms of
clamping down on uh media Outlets that
you disagree with or when it comes to a
lot of these social issues abortion and
gay marriage and the the right to fire
someone for their perceived sexual
orientation in those cases they seem
okay actually using the power of the
state
and uh what we saw under the first Trump
Administration we'll see if there's a
second Trump Administration but they
already learned that they could get away
with scooping up peaceful protesters and
shoving them into Vans and taking
through an undisclosed location that
doesn't seem especially libertarian on
the other hand uh as I said the uh
libertarianism uh today is a coalition
between business people who want to make
a lot of money and uh these principled
Libertarians and it is the business
people uh who I think are the prevalent
part of the Coalition and I should say
I'm not casting any aspersions on
business people the ordinary business
person in a well-regulated state can
feel pretty confident that if he's
making money he's doing good for the
world because somebody is buying his
product and if he were injuring innocent
third parties somebody from the
government would come and tell him that
and tell him to stop and the fact that
nobody tells him to stop means that he
can feel like he's done a good thing in
the world with his business you will not
be able to be confident of that under
Trump trump wants you to make money
whether you hurt people or not last
thing I wanted to touch on during the
pandemic there were a lot of again
self-described
Libertarians who were saying
um the vaccines that's a problem masks a
problem what's happening in school is a
problem a problem what businesses are
having to do for this initial period of
a few months that quite frankly ended
pretty quickly all of these things are a
problem what would a sort of more
sensible but still libertarian approach
be to those issues that we saw during
the pandemic
well it's pretty simple uh the the
liberal response which I think is the
right one is if government is proposing
to restrict somebody's Liberty it's got
to have a pretty good reason sometimes
the reason s are no good uh and
sometimes the story about arrogant
government bureaucrats is correct the
Centers for Disease Control came up with
a test that didn't work and wouldn't let
anybody else develop one it was a
scandal but on the other hand uh yeah a
lot of these restrictions certainly the
massive promotion of vaccines with tax
money and the requirement that health
care workers get vaccinated uh you know
it promotes people's Liberty it keeps
them alive in fact
we have been speaking about some of the
things in Andrew koppelman's new book
out today Burning Down The House how
libertarian philosophy was corrupted by
delusion and greed we're linking to the
book and I really appreciate your time
today here it is there it is a beautiful
cover yes thanks Andrew thank you this
was great